Russia's pushed to Annex four regions in
Ukraine has moved into a new phase with
authorities going door to door in what
they say are referendums armed soldiers
are reported to be forcing people to
vote the ballot is meant to decide
whether the occupied areas should join
Russia the votes are taking place in
luhansk donensk zaparisia and Hassan
they cover about 15 percent of Ukraine's
territory Ukraine's Western allies have
condemned the ballots as a sham that
appeared to be a step towards Russian
annexation meanwhile Moscow is
mobilizing military reservists as
President Vladimir Putin looks to
bolster his forces in Ukraine on
Wednesday the Kremlin announced 300 000
reserves would be sent to fight in
Ukraine in a moment we'll speak to Al
jazeera's Muhammad Val who's in Moscow
but first let's go to Gabriel alizondo
who joins us from cave hello there
Gabriel So reports armed soldiers are
going door to door or in these occupied
parts of the country how is that playing
out on the ground what are you hearing
yeah well it's important to again
remember that this is it's very hard to
get very clear information on what
exactly is happening where this voting
is taking place of course it's uh uh on
Ukrainian territory that is controlled
by Russian forces there are no
International independent election
monitors there and media movements are
incredibly restricted in that area with
that said uh what we're hearing from
various telegram channels and from
social media what we're hearing from
ukrainians that live in that area
talking to families that are outside of
the area where voting is happening is
that we are seeing evidence of Russian
appointed officials with military going
door to door in some instances and
apartment buildings knocking on doors
allegedly coercing people to vote or the
way they want them to vote we're also
hearing about ukrainians and some of
those those areas as well maybe closing
their windows on their homes shedding
their Gates trying to pretty much keep a
low profile and fear of having to be
forced to vote in a way that perhaps
they don't want to we're also seeing
other images put out by Russian sources
that appear to show a pretty normal and
organized voting happening in some areas
as well this is a huge area it causes
four different regions and all the
Voting is happening in slightly
different ways throughout the whole area
we are also hearing that some people
that are being asked to vote if they
show they have Russian passports they
are immediately given their papers to
join the Russian military so this is the
scene that we're starting to get a
picture we're starting to get painted
here on this second day of voting Russia
said they plan for this voting to end on
Monday when we expect at that point the
uh Russian Election Commission in Moss
scale will presumably start to release
some sort of what they say will be
results important again point out here
in Ukraine they are totally dismissing
this referendum out of hand they say and
you ask them and they'll jokingly and
not really jokingly even say we think
the results will probably be 99 as one
official told us uh in a way being
sarcastic saying that that's their way
of saying that that they believe Moscow
has the results of this uh referendum
predetermined
indeed and Gabe kievous a accusing a run
of supplying drones to Russia what more
do you know about those allegations
yeah Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski said that it Iran is
collaborating with evil by providing
drones to Russia that the Ukrainian
military says that the Russians are
using in here in Ukraine just on
Saturday the ukrainians announced they
shot down at least eight Iranian drones
that were being used by Russia and
because of this Ukraine announcing that
they are downgrading diplomatic
relations with Iran and forcing some of
their diplomats here in Kiev to leave
the country for Iran's part they say
that they are they are disappointed by
this and they say a spokesperson for the
Iran foreign Ministry says that Ukraine
should refrain from being influenced by
Third parties who seek to destroy
relations between the two countries but
clearly Ukraine is very upset about
Russia providing these drones I mean
Iran providing these drones to Russia
and is now taking some sort of action
against it all right thanks for bringing
us up to Spain Gabriel Elizondo live for
us in cave let's bring in Muhammad Val
now who's standing by in Moscow Muhammad
you've got some news on changes to
Russia's Military Department tell us
more
yes Emily the defense Ministry has
announced that the uh the deputy defense
minister for Logistics in the in in the
Russian army has been replaced by a new
top General Colonel General Mikhail Miss
himself served in Syria according to
Western sources in 2015 and he was part
of the
of the planning and execution of the
bombing of civilians in Aleppo again
according to to Western sources but
after that he became much more known for
his role in Mario port in the siege of
Mario Paul in April and May and that's
why the bridge foreign office placed him
under sanctions for what they accused
him of being being responsible for the
bombing of civilians there and for what
they described as atrocities in Mario
Paul now miss itself is in charge of the
logistics at a very crucial moment for
Russia in this conflict at a time when
there is a lot of criticism of the way
the whole Logistics operation has been
handled since the beginning of the of
this operation what Russia calls special
operation in Ukraine
we have seen the beginning of that
operation when hundreds of tanks were
placed in the wrong places and were
exposed to uh to uh to destruction in a
very brief time in various parts of of
Ukraine and now uh Russia is trying to
deploy 300 000 new uh young men to to
the to the front and it's the need is
high for a man who can control this
operation and make it successful
all right we appreciate the update
Muhammad Val live for us in Moscow